come
uncharted the Nathan Drake collection is
a history lesson on a grand scale it
weaves through maps journals and diary
entries long separated from their
ancient authors and abandoned ruins
across the world but this collection
also delves into this series own dark
recesses highlighting the progress
developer Naughty Dog made from the
first uncharted to the third there is
brilliance in this collection but there
are hints of mediocrity as well
it begins in 2007 when we first met
Nathan Drake he since become a video
game icon but eight years ago he was
Naughty Dog's first departure from the
affable jak and daxter at the time Drake
had yet to prove his worth the Uncharted
series combines third-person action
cover based shooting and cinematic
storytelling across its three
installments we followed our hero across
deserts between mountains and
underground through ancient tombs by
grouping all 3 ps3 titles together in
one place the Nathan Drake collection
comprises a larger story arc we can
experience the entire original journey
from beginning to end in 1080p at 60
frames per second but this adventurers
early moments are unsettling despite its
upgrades the first Uncharted has not
aged well drake's Fortune used to be an
enjoyable accomplished game but that was
in 2007 it looks gorgeous now it's lush
jungles greener it's shooting controls
tighter thanks to Blue Point games
refinements but set against modern
standards its overall quality is
middling Drake's movements are floating
and imprecise the cover mechanic placed
me in danger far too often climbing
sequences leave little room for error
often leading to death for unknown
reasons there are even rare storytelling
missteps at the perceived death of his
closest friend
Drake allows himself a single gasp for
morning is displaced by excitement for
another adventure waiting through
Drake's first outing means suffering
constant frustrations but in the end
it's still worth playing because of what
its story leads to uncharted 2 among
thieves
fantastic sequels successfully
modernised by improved cosmetics and
smoother aiming controls Naughty Dog's
characters show real complexity here and
the relationships shift aligned and
resettle as the story takes haphazard
turns its pacing is masterful as ever -
in slower sections where other
developers might falter Naughty Dog uses
endearing dialogue and cinematic shots
to give the story a sense of gravity
there is as they say never a dull moment
much of the same rings true and
uncharted 3 drake's Deception
although the pacing stumbles throughout
and the story inch
reduces supernatural elements in a
predictable manner Naughty Dog's
characterization is at its peak here
Drake's bright personality shows darker
shades Sully tries to anchor things with
a warm comforting presence and Alana's
apprehension for Drake mirrors our own
as we grow to question his actions
during what we once thought was the
final leg of his journey but as of this
writing we know uncharted 3 isn't the
end uncharted 4 is on the way and with
it the continuation of drake's story and
preparing us for the vagabonds encore
likely his final chapter Blue Point
Games has delivered a polished prelude
it's created a singular story arc
leading into the fourth chapter and
polished it all for modern visual
palettes like the best stories those of
Uncharted and its characters have
changed over time the Nathan Drake
collection smooths out those crinkled
pages clarifies the memories and buffs
all the right details in the retelling
of the story series at various times
throughout the Uncharted games
our protagonist carries the ring of
Francis Drake on a leather band around
his neck the rings inscription reads SiC
parvis Magna or greatness from small
beginnings and I can't imagine a better
way to encapsulate this collection
uncharted drake's fortune was a fine
game in 2007 but its wrinkles are deeper
now it's age more apparent but with
uncharted 2 and three Naughty Dog
transcended Drake's own small beginnings
the Nathan Drake collection is a
first-hand account of Naughty Dog's
growth as a storyteller this collection
is the best way to relive that history
and witness that transformation up close
what do you say we try this again my
friends call me something
Nathan Drake not Drake
okay
I see great things in our future kid
great things
you